I like in the upper right hand corner,
Maggot hat boy refuses to apologize
and infuriating interview.
That kid looked drugged and coached
like he was just probably both. Yeah,
it probably put them on some PROZAC.
Yeah, get out there. A little fella.
Apparently that native
American guy though,
they did an interview with him and it
was a disaster because he said a bunch of
things that just absolutely weren't true.
And they're questioning whether
or not he actually was in Vietnam.
He definitely didn't serve in Vietnam,
but he wasn't in combat. Right.
But you know, he had some,
some conflicting stories.
Yeah. None of these people were
prepared for this kind of attention.
It's like I was offended as as hell by
those kids and I'm a fucking big old
bleeding heart lefty for sure. And
I hate those, those fucking hats.
But like I in the state at the same time,
every teenage boys a fucking idiot.
Everyone, you know and like it's,
but those boys were standing there
doing their schools chance while these,
there's a long video and the video is
two hours long. I haven't watched it,
but I've watched segments of
it and in the segments of it,
you see those native American guys walk
up to those boys and chants with their
drums. So they're all there
for different reasons. Yeah.
So the boys were there
for the march for life,
which is a pro life march right there
from a Catholic school and they were
wearing their stupid red hats and then
the native American guy was there for for
a different reason. Yeah.
Well there are, there are a
couple, there was, there was a,
it was a native American celebration.
That's their yearly and you'd think
they'd coordinate these things.
There's all these different,
so a sort of marches going on and
that's all that's our right as citizens,
but it's just that they were all
in the Lincoln memorial together.
Well not only that, these boys
did not have like a good chaperon,
like boys were wild.
They yelled,
they said something like it's
not rape if you enjoy it. Yeah.
One kid yelled at again, by
the way, there's 40 kids want,
if you have one asshole kid doesn't mean
everybody should be beat up because one
of your stupid fucking classmates has
something really dumb because he thinks
he's funny.
Was 15,
I sat in an in an assembly once where
a friend of mine was in like, uh,
in Chicago to frame.
I was doing a play and they were doing
like a scene from the play on stage and a
woman would come on stage and they
would, these kids, these boys,
I'm behind him and they're saying
the worst shit I can imagine.
And it was just like Jesus Christ.
And if that,
it's that it's the race to the bottom,
like boys who can say the worst thing
I can, I can, I can yell the n word.
You know, it's staying where it shows your
tits. Yeah. Just trying to make a model.
And it's because, what's the
worst thing? Rape. Right.
So this kid's gonna yell something
about, right. It's, and it's, it's, uh,
I their children. Yeah. Yeah. I do
feel they need better supervision,
but here's the thing they do for sure,
but they shouldn't be judged publicly
on a global scale like this shop fair.
Yeah. I mean I, I disagree with uh,
pretty much everything them and
their parents stand for and stuff,
but it's their right to demonstrate,
you know what I mean?
So I mean they look did tear too young
to know what the fuck they're even
demonstrating a bounce to really
have a good argument about it.
Like to bring kids to a
pro live demonstration,
have them chat and yell their
schools songs and put on Maggie hats.
Like the whole thing is so fucked
up. It's really, well we're, I mean,
back to what I said about anxiety,
it's just where Eddie showed
there's fucking throats and like,
I mean I have a bit in my
act about how like, um, I,
I feel like the Internet was built for
us to tear each other apart because we're
just throwing darts and running away and,
and if you put us in a room together
and talk it out, we, I think we,
I think we would mano a Mano and
things like, you know, because we will,
the people, we all want the
same thing deep down inside.
We all want to take care of our kids.
We all want to have fun.
We all want an a bounty of a life, you
know? But I also say like, I'm also like,
I love people, but I fucking
hate people. Like it's like,
you know,
it's like if you go through a whole day
without speaking to another human being,
you ever had one of those days,
fuck, that was awesome. Isolation.
That was delicious. It's only if
you have too much though, right?
If you get get around people too much,
then those gap days where you just,
you could just recharge. Yeah. And then
you appreciate people when you see them.
Yeah. And do you get that where you,
where you go to, you're on the way,
the comedy store and you're
like, I want to fucking go. Like,
I don't want to go up right now. I'm
like, something's messing with me.
But it's like that with therapy,
comedy sometimes and the gym
sometimes where it's like,
I don't want to fucking go, but every
time I'm glad I did. You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I know what you're saying.
I could have a set where I eat shit and
I'll drive home laughing and I'm just
like, well, that didn't work.
The thing that bothers me most about
this is that they want the docs,
these kids and po address out
there in favor of that ever.
It's just so foolish ever.
They're treating them like they're
rational adults that are, you know,
fucking 50 years old that really
know what they're doing. No,
and it's not going to
solve anything. It's, no,
you're not going to convert these kids'
hearts and minds by ruining their lives.
You know?
I do understand the double standard we
have had with like black youth though,
where it's kind of like, uh, you know,
this kid gets strangled to death for
selling cigarettes and be like, Hey,
he's a criminal. It's like God damn it,
you know? Whereas these kids honestly,
cause they're wider getting
chance after chance after chance,
but I don't think they're last should
be ruined. It's like, I feel like we've,
we've, we've talked enough about it. These
kids did what they did. Let's move on.
Yeah. Well then you know, who knows what
they're getting chance after chance.
But during this situation,
like that's, this is,
this is the consequences of social media.
The fact that you could take a video
of someone doing something incredibly
stupid when they're 16 years old.
Yeah.
And what they did was
not even that stupid.
All he did to stand there and
smirk and people wanted him dead.
He was being a shithead.
But like I keep a YC,
if he's just standing there and
someone comes up to him beating a drum,
how are you supposed to react? I feel
like, how do you think you would rather,
I feel like the kid walked up to the
native Americans. Correct? Incorrect.
The kid was standing there,
the native American walked up to
him beating the drum. Okay. Walked.
Got Rid of the video.
That will, what happened?
What do you mean the guy was stabbed?
That kid wasn't in the video while the
native American gentleman was standing
there pounding as drumming.
There are kids around him,
but that kid that the main
kid wasn't there, he walked.
He ended up walking up to them.
Yeah. Okay. But the video that I saw,
the kid was standing there and that
guy walked up to him. Here's the thing.
This is two hours. There's the, the,
there's video of these people that's
two hours long and the video that I saw,
those kids were standing there chanting
and that guy walked to those kids and
was beating his drum.
If that one specific kid walked down,
but still that guy instigated it by
walking to them beating the drum.
Not only that that guy got in that kid's
face and beat that drum inches away
from his face, but I thought this
is also talking about that kid.
I thought that kid walked up to the,
to the native American. I'm not sure.
The native American guy walked
up to the whole group. Okay,
so you just take care of that.
Haven't seen all of that.
All of that video I saw American guy said
that they were saying build that wall,
build that wall. But there's no
evidence of that. Okay. The guy that,
the problem is the guy's a human native
American guys are human, right? Yeah.
And he's probably not prepared at
all for this kind of scrutiny. No.
And no one is,
there's a lot there.
There was an interview that he did with
CNN that is just full of holes. Okay.
And uh,
it doesn't match up to the video.
It doesn't match up to what happened
is like there's, this is all,
you could pull it, pull that
video, a pull that article,
but you try to find that
article, the CNN article. Um,
there was an article about the
article that I read. Either way. Yeah.
I'm just, I'm just inundated at this
point with all of it. I will say like,
you know, I've, I've said for
years, probably 15, 20 years now.
I'm so glad youtube did not exist
when I was in high school. Oh my God.
Cause you're just, you're just
a decent book. Yeah. Twitter,
the things that you would say on Twitter
or snapchat or any of those things.
Yeah. And I mean, I, I did
not grow up like, you know,
my parents generation being
mildly racist if you're white.
You know, I, I grew up, uh, pretty woke
as the kids say in Portland, Oregon.
So while you were in Chicago, Chicago's
pretty left wing will Chicago. I wasn't,
I wasn't there until I was born in
Chicago, but I grew up in Portland. Oh.
And then I was, yeah. But it was
also, it's funny, we had, uh,
we had,
we had right wing a Nazi groups
moving in when I was in high school,
uh, gangs from La and then from central
Oregon and further toward Idaho. You had,
you had a,
this,
this guy named Metzger who had like a
little little camp you cook on partying if
you've seen American history x.
It was just like that when you drink free
beer and they'd play punk rock music.
And the thing that everyone misses
when they look at those groups,
be it a gang or a white supremacist
skinhead group or whatever. It's,
it's,
it's a community first for people and
that's where they look at it first and
then they, they foreign community,
sadly over focusing hate.
But I just feel like kids back
here. Yeah. I mean, which kit?
So they're all, they walked up to
him being in there banging the drums.
That's the kid there and
standing there. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
There's a kid walking up to now,
but like you did right.
But he's just standing there.
The guy walked right up to him.
You're showing me in the video,
the guy walking up to the kid,
and this is exactly what I said, Jamie.
We walked right up to the kid here.
Was this the video?
I mean these kids all
mocking to traditional native
American music and rhythm,
but Jamie,
that native American guy just walked
up to that kid and got in his face.
It's clear as day.
I was just bringing up this like,
does this angle here he is standing here.
There's a group of kids around
them that kids might be managing.
This thing doesn't make any sense.
It's just the worst thing
for Philip to the kids.
He walked up to the kids and he walked
up to that kid specifically got in his
face. There was a certain amount
of separation between them.
He walked to the kid and got in his
face while he's beaten the drum. Okay,
play it again. I'm buying it right
now. He's, yeah, he's walking.
He's walking and the kid standing there
and when the kids 10 that he walks up to
the kid so, and they're
doing the Tomahawk Chop Chop.
They think it's funny. Like did they
understand that people are filming?
They don't.
So here he goes.
The whole thing is so strange.
So strange.
Because what are you supposed to do when
someone walks up to you beating a drum?
So there's the kid,
the kid standing there and the native
American guy now walks up to him
completely violating a space.
Now imagine if this is a man doing
this to a woman. You'd say, okay,
he's violating her space a 100% this is
fucked up and aggressive and that's what
this guy's doing. He's singing
this kid's face. It's a little kid.
And what is the kid supposed to do?
I don't know it. Should he walk away?
Should he say,
I'm sorry that someone in the
past stole your ancestors land?
What is he supposed to do? Yeah, I mean
I'm, no, I'm not saying yes, do that.
I'm saying what is the like the
question is what does your kid do?
But I mean these,
it's just he's,
I get why this guys approaching
because there's just a,
it's a river of people mocking
him and his culture. I get it.
But why this one kid and why?
Why get right in this guy's face or you're
beating a drum inches from this kid's
face. Yeah. That is the question and
what? Look, it's the fucking hat, man.
That goddamn polarizing. Stupid
hat, hate that had so much.
Look at these given closer to him.
He's put the drum off to the side so he
can get closer to this kid's face music.
Expecting the kid to walk away.
I don't know,
but the kid doesn't do anything but silly.
He's blinking because the,
the beating of the drum
is so close to his eyes.
It's weird. Yeah. The
whole thing is very weird.
So weird staring that kid down.
I mean,
why wouldn't you walk away just
to define why we don't know.
Everyone else walked away. But what
does he have to, doesn't happen.
He's standing there and the
guy decides to get in his face.
I think you would walk away probably
because the camera locked up on me.
I would, I would definitely move.
I think I would probably move to,
cause I'd be scared if that
guy got my face like that.
I think that guy's going to hit me.
I would, something's gonna go wrong.
And I'm like, this is good. This is
just too weird. But it's not the kids.
He's 16 minutes.
Yeah.
I the grownups fault for getting in a
16 year old kid's face beating a drum.
Yeah. It's just at that
fucking hat, man. I mean,
what's also the, he, the,
the native American man rightly
felt like he was being mocked. Yeah.
And then his traditions and his heritage
is being mocked and these little kids.
Yeah. I mean, I don't think he had the
right to walk up on the kid like that,
but it's like where, where is your
breaking point? Well, wait a minute.
I don't think he doesn't have the right,
but this is where
confrontation comes from.
Do you have the right to
make confrontation? Yep.
Maybe. Perhaps May. Perhaps,
but that's not really the best way
to communicate. You're seeing a song,
a native American song,
and he doesn't know what the fuck you're
singing and you're doing it inches from
his face. Yeah. And everyone's felt,
it's a really a sign of the Times that
people took clips of that and they made
it out.
Like this little kids that comment and
even raise the Osl on head on is if you
ever seen him more punchable
face like, man, that's your,
you're calling for violence on a kid,
is that what you're doing? It's, it's,
it's the same, uh, you know,
level of, and again, you know,
as kids, like even when you
were pulling that clip up,
I could feel my stomach make a
fist and I'm like, oh, this just,
I don't want to see this.
But you know, uh, like it,
it's like that dude that,
that, that his, that,
that kid at the cub game
who had the game in his,
in his ear phones and he caught the ball,
which the outfielder was definitely
not going to catch anyway.
And they blamed him for the cubs lost of
the series and they had to escort that
kid out. And I thought the kid
reached forward though. He did. But I,
if you look at the tape, I don't
think that the outfielder had it now.
Outfitter was pointing
like you fucked up kid,
like you ruined it and
it was kind of this,
I understand when you're
playing major league ball,
one mistake could mean the end of your
career, your family's and what I saw.
I think that's different. When I saw that,
I thought that kid fucked up the game.
It, it could be argued, yes, you know
what I'm talking about. Absolutely. Yeah,
but that's like you're staying there
with blaming one tiny play on the entire
game and you can't do that.
And the fact,
the fact that back to what your
point of punched the kid in the face,
that kid had to be escorted out at
Wrigley field because people were going to
kill him,
but they were drunk people that we're
going to throw hit that kid into traffic.
Can we see that video of the
guy who can pull that up?
I think that kid actually
did fuck up that game.
I think the difference is that kid
reached into the playing field.
What he did was definitely wrong and
illegal and let's see, I had everything,
but yeah, let's check
it out. Tail the tape.
Steve Park. There's the ball. It's
going, it's going. It's going.
Wait a minute. Let me say it one
more time. Back that up. No, no, no,
but just bag it up so slow.
Okay.
I mean, I think I take it
back. I had, I had, uh,
I think
it one more time. I think I
remembered it wrong. Oh yeah.
Stole it.
They stole
it from him. Fuck. I'd see and
take it all back. He had the ball.
I take it all back. That kid fucked it
up. Yeah. The literally did. He took it.
He literally took it from him in the
playing field. Yeah. You little cunt.
Oh,
he's got spray on them.
People probably through
beers on them probably,
but the thing of like threatening
a kid's life, that's crazy.
But also it's like if you're a
kid and the ball's right there,
you're going to reach for it.
You're not going to be thinking
this guy's going to catch her,
not going to catch it. It's like
you have a chance to catch the ball.